sie haben gerade das Thema Migration
Zuwanderung schon angesprochen Herr
Stegner ganz schnelle Schätzfrage oder
vielleicht für Sie auch eine
Wissensfrage wie groß ist der Anteil an
Ausländern bei Hartz IV wissen sie das
nee ich weiß das nicht aber ich vermute
schon dass es ein erheblichen Anteil
gibt und dass ich jedenfalls da eine
Menge mehr tun können um
20% keine Ahnung
20 Prozent vielleicht 20%, das sind 20
Kilometer nicht es sind tatsächlich
mittlerweile 45% und die Zahl ist
deswegen so wichtig weil sich das extrem
verändert hat in den vergangenen Jahren
im Jahr 2015 also vor der großen
flüchtlingskrise waren das ja bei weitem
nicht 45% damals hatten wir 4,6
Millionen Deutsche in Hartz IV und 1,3
Millionen Ausländer heute stand jetzt 3
Millionen deutsche Nation 25% 2,4
Millionen Ausländer was dann 45 Prozent
ausmacht
über eine Million ähm
was zu tun ja aber was heißt zum
Beispiel und nicht wissen Sie was das
zeigt nach dagegen
dürfen dass wir dass wir ganz lange in
der Politik um dieses Problem völlig
drumherum geredet haben wir sind nicht
in der Phase wo wir hier über
vierköpfige deutsche Familie sprechen wo
Mama und Papa ganz zufällig und durch
Pech arbeitslos geworden sind sondern
wir reden massiv im Moment über ein
Zuwanderungsproblem in unsere
Sozialsysteme Herr Stein was sagen sie
zu diesen Zahlen 45
aber auf der anderen Seite haben wir ja
jahrelang zugeschaut ich kann mir
erinnern da waren früher die die Polen
die die Spargel gesprochen haben dann
waren sie Ukraine die die Spargel
gestochen hat unsere wir haben immer
mehr uns selber und es kommt selber wird
mehr verzichtet war berühmtes sozial
Teppiche hatten diese Arbeit selbst zu
übernehmen und das ist ein Problem den
wir wirklich massiv entgegenwirken
müssen aber die Zahlen sagen ja dass das
neue Bürgergeld massiv eben an diese
Menschen an diese Familie bezahlt werden
wird und diese Zahlen hat in den
vergangenen Monaten in der öffentlichen
Debatte um das Bürgergeld komischerweise
niemand auf dem Tisch gelegt da Stegner
warum eigentlich nicht warum haben sie
diese Zahl gar nicht präsent gehabt das
ist ja eine Zahl gerade weil so viel
Dynamik da drin ist die entscheidend ist
für die Finanzierbarkeit unsere
Sozialsysteme das tun die Flüchtlinge
aus der Ukraine ganz gewissen nicht
sondern weil wir sie nicht haben
arbeiten lassen das ist doch der Punkt
Hartz IV war doch die Absicherung für
diejenigen die keine Arbeit haben und
Sie arbeiten zu lassen ihre
Qualifikation zu nutzen das ist die
Aufgabe das haben die Konservativen
bekämpft und ich muss Ihnen mal was
sagen wenn Sie hier immer so tun als sei
dass das Paradies Herr Weise leben sie
mal im Jahr vom Bürgergeld und sagen Sie
mal wie sieht das finden ob sie das so
komoot finden dass sie das gerne machen
ich glaube nicht das ist auch nicht das
Thema Leute wollen dass das
ist mein Thema jetzt mal das ist mein
Thema weil sie sagen zu war noch nicht
Sozialsysteme entschuldigung das ist
wirklich Propaganda hier wandert
niemanden die Sozialsysteme zu sondern
es geht darum dass er den Leuten die
hierher kommen zum Beispiel als
Flüchtlinge eine Perspektive geben dass
sie arbeiten können dass sie anständig
bezahlen Sozialsysteme Sozialtransfers
ist das was die Nothilfe ist und nicht
der Regelfall und wir sollten nicht so
tun leistungsloses bedingungsloses
Einkommen wollen ich verstehe ihre
Aufregung weil das die Debatte stört
möglicherweise im politischen Berlin
aber die Zahlen auf den Tisch zu legen
ist keine Propaganda ja das ist eine
ganz wichtige Debatte in Deutschland zu
führen weil eben ja der Versuch ist all
diese Menschen zu integrieren in
Deutschland und weil das ja offenbar
Herr hück nicht gelingt mit den Mitteln
die wir haben weil das mit den
hartz-iv-sätzen im Moment nicht gelungen
ist seit 2015 all diese Menschen in den
deutschen Arbeitsmarkt zu integrieren
Stiftung wo ich ja sozial Benachteiligte
gerade vorwiegend die die mir jetzt
gerade angesprochen haben in die Arbeit
in in Brot wieder hinein gebe ich rede
mit den Unternehmern könnt ihr bitte die
im sage ich mal im Handwerk nehmen und
sie brauchen keine Angst vor mir haben
sondern ich tue die Leute schützen
schützen indem ich die die Wahrheit sagt
das Leben hat nichts mit schmusen zu tun
und nichts mit Küssen sondern es hat was
mit Leist zu tun Fördern und Fordern und
viele ich habe ich habe Flüchtlinge bei
uns gehabt der ist heute Mechatroniker
ist Deutscher Meister und tut seine
Arbeit und sein Geld selber verdient ist
sowas tolles aber warum brauche ich eine
lernstiftung in Deutschland wo ich
selber finanzieren muss warum macht es
der Staat nicht warum du da unter
Bildungssystem wir haben ein eine
Marotte Bildungssystem warum tut man da
nichts
heute vorsichtig gesagt überrascht haben
die FAZ hat heute groß darüber berichtet
hat diese Zahlen auf dem Tisch gelegt
und wir alle haben mir gesessen und
haben gedacht warum ist es eigentlich
nicht längst bekannt und das Beispiel
Stegner uns allen wäre das jetzt gerade
auch so gegangen in der Runde beweist
auch ja Mensch das hat keiner auf dem
Zettel das ist ein riesiges Problem dass
es im Moment nicht gelingt überhaupt
anzusprechen Herr scherde waren na gut
also ich muss da an dieser Stelle
tatsächlich auch darauf hinweisen dass
wir jetzt sehr vorsichtig sein müssen
dass wir zum Beispiel die ukrainischen
geflüchteten die an einem aktuellen
Krieg entfliehen oder können wir genau
sind gegen diejenigen die in Deutschland
jetzt riesiger Arbeitslosigkeit genau da
muss man sehen
weil das Ganze tatsächlich natürlich
sensibel ist das Thema wir können die
Zahlen ganz klar benennen und wir können
ganz klar sagen dass es 600.000 derzeit
sind die
Ukraine aus der Ukraine gekommen sind
als geflüchtete und die hier
Sozialleistung beziehen dass es über
eine Million Menschen sind seit 2015 die
aus dem Asylsystem sozusagen aus den
asylleistung rausgefallen sind und
mittlerweile eben Hartz IV beziehen die
Zahlen kann man auf den Tisch legen und
man sieht eine ganz eindeutige
Entwicklung in den vergangenen Jahren
meine Frage war schlicht weil uns diese
Zahlen überrascht haben wie gehen wir
damit um ich finde das ist ein klares
Indiz dafür dass das Hartz-IV-System
komplett versagt hat deshalb komplett
versagt darin Menschen zu qualifizieren
bisschen deutsche oder geflüchtete sind
an dieser Stelle und sie wirklich in den
Arbeitsmarkt zu bringen und jeder
Schritt der da an Qualifikation oder
Anerkennung von Berufsabschlüssen zum
Beispiel die geflüchte aus der Ukraine
sind ja in der Regel auch sehr gut
ausgebildet entsprechend europäischer
Standards und so weiter und so fort die
können natürlich schnell auch auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt integriert werden aber
dafür muss der Staat dann eben
entsprechend auch die Voraussetzungen
schaffen damit geht man beim Bürgergeld
einen Schritt in die richtige Richtung
wenn es denn kommt wenn die Union ihre
also die cdu/csu ihre auf Fake News
basierende Kampagne endlich einstellt an
dieser Stelle worin bestehen die Fake
News ja man muss auch an dieser Stelle
natürlich sagen dass gerade führende
Unionspolitiker sagen dass die Menschen
die das Bürgergeld kassieren am Ende und
ich finde auch natürlich muss man
berechtigterweise Menschen die von Armut
bedroht sind oder von Arbeitslosigkeit
betroffen auch als Staat Geld zur
Verfügung stehen damit die ihr Leben
gestalten können dass die am Ende dann
mehr haben als diejenigen die sich jeden
Morgen aus dem Bett quälen aber wir
haben ja schon geklärt und ich bin Ihnen
sehr dankbar bei der eingehenden
Moderation haben sie gesagt es gibt
einen zu geringen Abstand aber es gibt
einen Lohnabstand aber das Problem ist
dass im niedrig und Sektor die Löhne zu
gering sind dass der Steuersystem da
nicht funktioniert dass die Anreize zu
wenig sind dann tatsächlich dort
halten wir gleich weiter Schütte waren
ich möchte noch einmal bei dem Punkt
bleiben da wir bezahlen gerade gehört
haben Herr Stegner und der Schirdewahn
sagt jetzt ja ganz genau das ist das
Versagen auch von Hartz IV wir haben all
diesen Flüchtlingen all diesen den wir
Asyl gewährt haben hier in Deutschland
den ist es nicht gelungen mit Hartz IV
eine Arbeitsplatz zu vermitteln die
haben wir nicht integrieren können über
Arbeit wie lösen Sie das Problem jetzt
mit dem Bürgerkriegen
meine Schätzung war ja durchaus gar
nicht falsch das war bis vor kurzem bei
25 % es gibt zu viele Flüchtlinge den
wir nicht erlaubt haben zu den wir nicht
erlaubt haben zu arbeiten die Union war
immer dagegen die aus Afghanistan werden
ja bald wieder abgeschoben die braucht
man ja nicht arbeiten lassen das ist
doch eine Chimäre gewesen wir müssen die
Leute arbeiten reden sie mal wir sind
damit die Unternehmensverbänden nein
nicht die sagen das doch die Leute bitte
arbeiten und schiebt die nicht auch noch
ab man hat hier gut integrierte Leute
abgeschoben die gerne arbeiten möchten
stattdessen sitzen Straftäter hier die
wir nicht abschieben können der Punkt
ist wirklich der dass wir diejenigen die
zu uns kommen und hier schreiben
qualifizieren müssen und sie arbeiten
lassen müssen da war die SPD uns immer
dafür das machen wir jetzt die Ampel
sorgt dafür dass das geschieht
deswegen weil sie keine Arbeit haben
dieses Systems an dieser Stelle will
aber noch mal sagen das
Schlimme gehört und gesehen haben der
wirft ihn vor kurzem zu haben
sie genau sie haben doch Hartz IV
Regelung sagen
mit den entsprechenden Arbeitsminister
jetzt nicht sagen an dieser Stelle immer
dafür gewesen sind dass das nicht dazu
kommt und dass die Leute schneller in
den Arbeitsmarkt sie haben doch die
hören erst aufgebaut und das gilt für
sowohl geflüchtete auch für deutsche an
dieser Stelle haben die schlimmsten
geflüchte in diesem Alter sind die
Steuerflüchtlinge gehören das sind
nämlich enorm wenn die endlich ihr Geld
hier versteuert
dann würde er gar nicht mehr über
Bürgergeld Reden an dieser Stelle und
über die wir jedes Problem in
Deutschland
nicht einfach darum dass die Politiker
versagt haben Integration hier
einzuführen in Deutschland man hat sie
einfach manchmal auch getexelt zum
Beispiel geduldet da darf gar nicht an
Deutschland arbeiten das zeigt einfach
die Bundesregierung erlaube ich dir
nicht und das ist das wo ich sage die
geduldeten möchten gerne arbeiten ich
kenne sie sie dürfen aber nicht arbeiten
unsere Schuld
da müssen wir Änderungen machen der in
Deutschland ist muss arbeiten und nicht
erst nach einem Jahr oder zwei Jahre das
ist tatsächlich so tun aber gerade so
als wenn Du das erste Mal wäre in der
Geschichte Deutschlands dass wir
Integration Integration betrieben werden
wir haben die Russlanddeutschen
aufgenommen ein über 1,5 Millionen jeder
kennt die Zahlen hier und haben immer es
geschafft Leistungsanreize zu bieten
genau und es war nicht unbedingt das
hörige halt so Anreize
zusammen reden
wir müssen aufpassen dass wir das alles
so runter reden und immer so tun als
wenn er damit alles abgedeckelt wird die
Leute müssen wieder Spaß an dem haben
was
genau
einstellen aber ich würde es zum
Beispiel warum machen wir nicht
erweiternde Bundeswehr haben wir doch
auch gehabt weil weil Arbeit war ja auch
Arbeitsplatzbeschaffung aber damals
damals war das so die Menschen sind zu
uns gekommen und haben erstmal keine
Starthilfe bekommen die haben hier mit
der Arbeit anders gemacht die haben sich
die abgearbeitet in Deutschland aber die
haben sie geschämt sie haben sie
geschämt hier was zu holen in der Tat
das muss man ganz ja gerade in der 60er
70er Jahren das sind die gekommen und
haben gesagt ich will arbeiten ich will
arbeiten wir müssen wieder die
Motivation der Arbeit nach vorne bringen
wir müssen Arbeit wieder stolz machen
wir müssen die Leute stolz machen die im
Handwerk sind nein du wirst heute nur
noch stolz gemacht wenn du studiert hast
Studierenden brauchen wir auch aber wir
brauchen das Handwerk wir müssen die
Leute wieder loben der den Mülleimer aus
lernen das ist ein geiler Typ den muss
man loben dieses Lob vermisse ich von
der Politik die reden viel zu viel über
Studierende wir müssen wieder die
einfachste Arbeit loben und die Leute
her hochheben dann funktioniert es in
Deutschland undisziplin da bin ich für
ein regional überzeugt dass da das
müssen wir wieder einführen wir müssen
die Fahne des Handwerk und Mittelstand
nach oben heben alles andere
ergänzen vielleicht es gehört auch dazu
dass die Medien bereit sind mal alle
gemeinsam mal das Thema Freude an der
Arbeit wieder zu nehmen es hätte mich
gewonnen das wäre die erste Sendung die
so zu Ende gegangen wäre in der die
Mädchen schuld gewesen
wir werden versuchen den beim Freude an
der Arbeit bei allen weiter zu wecken
Herr steigt
[Musik]